un funeral con todos los honores
militares y reales en un silencio
sombrío
el príncipe felipe decidió que su
ceremonia fúnebre fuera así y sus deseos
se cumpliera la procesión comenzó a las
14 45 hora de londres el féretro fue
trasladado desde el castillo de windsor
hasta la capilla san jorge' en un land
rober que el mismo duque de edimburgo
ayudó a diseñar
detrás marcharon sus cuatro hijos
mientras la reina isabel segunda de 94
años iba a bordo de un automóvil bentley
su primera aparición desde el
fallecimiento de su esposo los príncipes
william y harry caminaron separados por
su primo peter phillips la relación de
los dos hermanos ha sido tensa desde que
harry y su esposa megan ausente del
evento renunciaron a sus deberes reales
a las 15 horas con la puntualidad
británica hubo un minuto de silencio
nacional
solo 30 asistentes y distanciados entre
sí por las restricciones del cob y 19 la
reina se sentó sola
mientras un coro de tan solo 4 personas
protagonizaba los cánticos el duque
decidió que su ataúd estuviera envuelto
en su estandarte personal y fuera
decorado con su gorra su espada de la
marina real y una corona de flores
también optó por que el servicio
anglicano no tuviera sermones ni
lecturas familiares sólo unas cuantas
palabras de los dos religiosos que
precedieron la ceremonia we spain in
spain is our hemos sido inspirados por
su lealtad inquebrantable a nuestra
reina por su servicio a la nación y el
commonwealth por su coraje fortaleza y
fe fosis your hands face
finalmente el ataúd del príncipe felipe
descendió a la bóveda real con las
cornetas de los marines al fondo tocando
la alerta que usan para prepararse a la
batalla y que el príncipe pidió
personalmente para su entierro
god save the queen' cerró el funeral
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y sin más se fue la reina isabel
[Música]